I'm using enough hemp and you know so
many of the things that we're here at
this conference where hemp is a
revolutionary material it could be of
course made into clothing it can be used
to make you know biofuel it actually
pulls a tremendous amount of carbon out
of the air so there are certain things
where you're like oh wow if we just
realigned a lot of the materials and
resources around this right that's a
good one I like that I mean okay let's
let's get meta because I have a feeling
you you you're an ideas person so your
average person right now is bombarded
with so many things we're looking at
students being bombarded with debt for
example we're looking at the economy is
in the middle of a hidden recession in
fact it's heartbreaking in New York we
now have as many homeless people like
during the height of the Great
Depression and so that's a critical sign
I mean something's really wrong mental
health economic consistency you know the
living wage so that's going to get
deeper a weirder and it's more and more
electronic media and other forms of
artificial intelligence other things
kick in people are gonna be radically
displacement economy the fact they
already are in New York as you walk down
any Street you're going to notice a lot
of empty storefronts as well because the
landlord's won't adjust there are rental
rates and they'd rather sit on an empty
space and then have a chain store come
in and get rid of the mom-and-pop
businesses small businesses stuff like
that so it's there the nickname right
now here they're saying its retail
apocalypse San Francisco you're probably
facing a similar crisis because of the
tech sector and the housing you know
kind of issues and the homeless I just
walked around this morning a homeless
thing here is pretty deep too it is so
those are geolock ellipse is also pretty
real across so everyone is getting all
their critical information financial
information from the internet so the
whole economy now is now people are
being conditioned to consume far more
than they need and things like that like
hyper advertisers hyper consumerism
so these are things that were just
creation right and creating it's like is
meaningful right it gives people like I
said the dignity of work or dignity of a
sense of engagement someone's opinion
may contradict yours
why is my friend Alan it's all about
your perspective
who are we in what is the nature of this
reality what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Sakia we
are on site at the beautiful new West
summit number five the cannabis tech
conference we are now going to be
talking to Paul Miller aka DJ Spooky
what's up Paul yeah what's up hey you
don't thank you so much for coming on
the show really appreciate it yeah I
just got off a flight from New York and
as always the weather here and San Cisco
is gorgeous I love California you guys
don't even know mattis so it's so nice
out here we don't got the six months of
freezing cold temperatures that's right
right Paul's background so interesting
musician futurist a Google artist in
residence so teach us about what you've
been up to with composing multimedia art
writing tell us about what you were
passionate about okay so just for those
out there in the world who are you know
just newcomers to my vibe so my name is
Paul Miller aka DJ Spooky I'm a writer
artist a musician a composer basically I
live in New York but I travel all the
time so a lot of my work it looks at the
connection between technology art and
music simple three things but the glue
that holds together is a kind of a
passion for social justice and
environmental justice and many of those
issues come out of I think you know both
my parents are professors when I was a
kid my father was Dean of Howard
University's law school and my mother
was a historian of design so I kind of
just grew up in a household of valued
and respected information a lot but here
we are and it's sort of I am so hesitant
to say the Trump era but yeah and so
information and technology meanwhile are
far outstripping many of the social
dynamics of our time so if you look at
what's going on with politics versus the
the arts or the arts are far more
engaged with technological evolution at
the moment
businesses from my own opinion and
meanwhile a lot of the policies that are
being engendered is especially with this
current administration and so on so tech
is evolving but art is not keeping up as
fast as text no in fact art is moving is
just as fast and in content and ammaji
but I feel politically speaking a lot of
the policies that we're seeing just are
hamstringing people and like not
necessarily enabling creative
flourishing yeah yeah that's a good way
to voice yeah yeah um tell us about how
you see tech art and music collaborating
for social justice and environmental
justice right I mean half the battle
right now is critical thinking like
getting people just to be aware of how
many variables are you know in play and
so for me at least again like we're here
at a cannabis conference and you know I
barely even smoke but I'm very
respectful of the whole issue of the
innovation so I'll give you a funny
example is like the decriminalization of
all of the stuff that we're here at this
conference
you know sparked an entire new economy
and that has helped so many people but
at the same time it could be more
dynamic and more I'm a big fan of like
once you get like the innovation going
to create more and more feedback loops
you can create a much more robust
situation so Canada for example took a
similar approach but then blew the door
open because they were far more dynamic
with their policies at a governmental
level your your average American and
entrepreneur is burdened with a
tremendous amount of yeah ambiguity I
mean Jeff's essence the guy was the
former attorney general created a
nightmare because he personally just I
don't know what his again these people
are they're crazy you just crazy so old
ethos old code yeah evil and stupid
that's you know just es dumb but at the
end of the day a lot of the way that
when you say cold code versus new code
that's that's a much more polite way of
saying it but my best to respect
humanity no matter what that's a good
one I mean I'm working on that at the
moment man it's just like here we are
you wake up any you know any human being
who's rub two brain cells together and
you see climate change
you know fires floods crazy migrations
of insects they're being going extinct
like bees butterflies also at the edge
of extinction all sorts of stuff that's
happening and it's like people just how
do you incentivize them to care you know
so do you feel like you're pushed into
tech music and art Cowan collaborating
can then entice that and catalyze that
big change that we need for social
justice and environmental change and how
would you see it also doing that I mean
it's been a powerful couple of weeks I
was just in New York for climate week
and I had a big event with Bill McKibben
who's you know a friend and just a
really for lack of it were at serious
catalyst for rethinking climate change
and it was amazing to see Greta toon
Berg was his younger when we was like 16
she did a talk battery park where like I
don't even know like 200,000 people
people have reached a tipping point all
puns intended you know whether the
awareness is there but policy I'm using
enough hemp and you know so many of the
things that were here at this conference
for hemp is a revolutionary material it
can be of course made into clothing it
can be used to make you know biofuel it
actually pulls a tremendous amount of
carbon out of the air so there are
certain things where you're like oh wow
if we just realigned a lot of the
materials and resources around us we're
using stuff and you're talking about old
code we're using stuff badly like our
buildings are old building code like I
hate air conditioning for example in New
York the summer this summer in 2019 the
the electricity went out because
everyone turn on their air conditioner
so the next person turn on the air
conditioner and then everyone turned on
the air conditioner and it overloaded
the system I'm just giving you one
example where as if everyone had turned
off their conditioners and let the
breeze we're right in the middle of a
river you could just let the you know
there's a nice breeze coming in but
instead everyone wants that air
conditioner I'm just giving you one
example
there's zillions of others and so half
the battle is just get people to think
more critically about the world around
them and the materials and things that
we can we can do better so tell us about
your process then with tech art and
music and how you then find specific
things like cannabis how do you embed
that within your framework that you use
and then how do you distribute that
content across platforms to catalyze the
change that we want to see um well at
the moment you're catching me right when
I'm finishing a whole bunch of projects
so for if you ask me the same question
2020 I'll have a lot more concrete
specifics so I have a new album that I'm
almost done with called the invisible
hand and that's with the guys from the
band the police which is a for
Millennials out there I have to say
there was a band called the police not
NWA after police but Bell Police so
Stewart Copeland's the drummer is a
legendary figure he lives out here in
California that project is looking at
cryptocurrency and we're gonna turning
the whole album into a kind of a
cryptocurrency approach to music and
like smart contracts publishing yeah
then let's see I'm finishing a book
called digital fictions the future of
storytelling where I sort of dig into
how stories shape perception so
narrative is critical especially in this
time where we're looking at what you
call computational propaganda where
you're looking at algorithmic narrative
like I'll give you example again like
collaborative filtering on stuff like
Twitter Facebook and so on if you click
on the like or whatever it the the smart
everybody call neural networks deep
learning actually begins to shape and
mold all the things that you see around
you so you live in a bubble and you
actually won't be able to get any
information outside of what you've
already clicked and like because you
keep getting small reference points I'm
just giving you that as a civilian
there's it gets deep but so you're
hitting all of these different fields
you're hitting you know copied
computational propaganda algorithmic
bias filter bubbles but you're also
bridging into into social justice and
environmental adjust this interesting so
then how would you then
see something like your books you know
your book sounds really interesting this
is digital they yeah Digital fictions in
the future the future of storytelling
that's a full-time the future
storytelling so interesting because then
from someone that's literally focused on
how the different methodologies for
storytelling are going to be exploding
around our world you see yourself both
recording albums and distributing albums
with partners like the police and then
you also see yourself writing books
distributing other content across your
platforms okay so you're really going
mult broad multimedia and also multi
field multi disciplines yeah interesting
and then does it does it feel like music
or does it feel like writing does it
feel like one of these is landing in the
hearts at a deeper level music has this
ability like bypass the gatekeeper right
so that's a good one I like that I mean
okay let's let's get meta because I have
a feeling you you you're an ideas person
so your average person right now is
bombarded with so many things we're
looking at students being bombarded with
death for example we're looking at the
economy is in the middle of a hidden
recession in fact it's heartbreaking in
New York we now have as many homeless
people as during the height of the Great
Depression and so that's a critical sign
I mean something's really wrong mental
health economic consistency you know the
living wage so that's going to get
deeper a weirder as more and more
electronic media and other forms of
artificial intelligence other things
kick in people gonna be radically
displacing the economy the fact they
already are in New York as you walk down
any Street you're gonna notice a lot of
empty storefronts as well because the
landlord's won't adjust their rental
rates and they'd rather sit on an empty
space and then have a chain store come
in and get rid of the mom-and-pop
businesses the small businesses stuff
like that so it's like they're the
nickname right now near they're saying
its retail apocalypse San Francisco
you're probably facing a similar crisis
because of the tech sector and the
housing you know kind of issues and the
homeless I just walked around this
morning a homeless thing here is pretty
deep - it is so those are Jackalopes is
also pretty real
across the middle of the United States
it's been for a while yeah so everyone
is getting all their critical
information financial information from
the internet so that means just quickly
also this is also similar for other
countries around the world where Alibaba
is doing the distribution - right so
this is happening all over the place so
there's people then we'll need to find
some sort of dignity and humanity and
meaning in life when their work is
displaced by artificial intelligence
right and so that's how most it's almost
a forked old conclusion I mean I think
we are looking at a radical shift of the
economy and so my book digital fictions
now usually published with MIT so for
those out there Massachusetts Institute
of Technology it's one of the best tech
schools in the country but this one I'm
doing with Duke University Press and
again I'm not finished with it yet
because this landscape keeps changing
every couple weeks there's new
developments and evolution like the
other day I was there's a really I'm not
I'm gonna pivot back to what we're just
talking about but so when you look at
the economics of like the last couple
centuries it's been the basic production
of physical goods and the idea of
scarcity but if we circle back to the
21st century we're now moving more and
more into an attention economy so
influencers all sorts of people are
making millions of dollars off of clicks
and likes in fact billions I mean you
know so the eerie thing about physical
goods versus perceptual goods I mean
literally economists call it perceptual
goods like how many clicks likes and so
on you know if you look at Facebook if
you look at all the major the Furious
Five as we call it you know in hip-hop
it's a I used the term the Furious Five
cousins Grandmaster Flash and the
Furious Five but Fang is another one
right so you got Microsoft Amazon
Facebook Apple it's a Google so so all
of that is not necessary that sac onsen
tration of wealth and so we're now I
think just facing the notion of a
critical transition part of that has to
do with the creative economy which means
there's a narrative storytelling new
methods of you know podcasts are huge
right now
everything so all of those are people
coming into a better sense of
consciousness that's my own take you
know on a writing a book about this
something always research on the other
end of the spectrum you have the
political system that thrives on
ignorance and so because of that like a
Trump is a perfect example
you know they've thrown up this huge
radioactive smokescreen around Trump
policies like hemp should have been
legalized decades ago realistically and
it's a great material or never illegal
yeah never right yeah always used as a
tool for spiritual ascension yeah across
all different and even the first
American flags are made from hemp you
know if you want to go back to deep old
school if you look at any of the first
you know flags at 13 colonies they were
made from him so I chuckle about that
because here we are in 21st century so
we're facing a crisis of climate because
we're gonna be seeing much more climate
refugees if you look at the
Mediterranean if you look at what's
going on in the south of America right
now all those states are gonna be
hammered with storms like a lot more and
then of course global warming with the
ice sheets and Arctica all this has to
turn to how people tell themselves the
story when they wake up in the morning
yeah so amusingly enough people are
calling this air at the end throughout
the scene area yes
so the human impact on our planet is
unquestionably changing things climate
change is man-made by far humans are the
greatest impact factor the greatest
variable on the trajectory of the planet
now right so the Anthropocene era means
P it's about people so I'm just kind of
riffing on that with you for a second
because I'm fascinated with we can all
change me we could wake up tomorrow and
there's a very famous phrase from Adam
Smith who's generally considered to be
the Godfather of liberal economic theory
where he says all money is an illusion
and so he takes it even further says all
money is a matter of belief like you
believe in a currency or you don't
yeah and if you know like if you look at
market forces if you perceive something
going down I'm using off everyone else
will start selling and the market
crashes or if everyone starts seeing
something going up
starts it's amazing because you can
actually quantify that and like I'm a
regular runner for example Oh give me
just a moment to everyone hold on let me
get that sensor back on yeah all right
like the fact you just have to do a
little Corey out a little yeah we're
gonna do the little dance and then with
the dancing about architecture yeah move
in there so yeah I mean these are all
things that can change I firmly believe
that the human psyche the human spirit
sways towards the good the problem is
it's levels of awareness levels of
ignorance and manipulation you know it's
like so the whole economy now is now
people are being conditioned to consume
far more than they need and things like
that like hyper advertising hyper
consumerism so these are things that
versus creation right and creating it's
like is meaningful right and gives
people like you said the dignity of work
the dignity of a sense of engagement so
as we move further into 21st century
these are things aren't that's on my
mind right now and as we're a canvas
convention it's kind of cool to see a
lot of people innovating and trying to
come up with new approaches so I've been
walking around a little bit and just get
a sense of what's happening it sounds
like the if maybe the correct me if I'm
wrong this biggest principle to take
away is a fire in the morning every
morning that can bring great value to
yourself to your family to your
community to the world and by having
that and by that sort of a meaning and
drive having that fire is could be some
of the biggest solutions to social
justice to environmental issues to the
artificial intelligence future that
we're moving into yeah an amusing enough
man it takes more money to put somebody
in jail than to send it to Harvard I
mean it's like there were some really
funny articles not funny well funny bad
not funny good so maybe some social
scientists and other people who
argue that it's just it's it's it's we
are all born with different cognitive
capacities and so in order to be able to
to help get someone excited about
learning and to put their trajectory
towards finding a North Star rather than
becoming incarcerated is the big thing
there to figure out right I mean so when
you talk about finding your North Star I
love that phrase because North for
african-american culture during the
slave time was where you had to guilt
for freedom so people would literally
follow the North Star and there was the
Underground Railroad all sorts of stuff
that would give you a narrative of again
a narrative where people are saying
follow the star follow the solvus so it
was still a story and it was still a
kind of if you look at all the earlier
African American hymns which of course
then became blues or then became hip-hop
and so on amusing if the DNA was always
about liberation and attaining freedom
the song after song story after story so
I'm a big fan of that right now what we
need is better narratives a better
stories to give people a sense of being
a stakeholder and change some people are
like oh we need a revolution we got a
wipeout everything I actually think the
better solution is is giving one or two
generations of people better critical
thought tools and you could see the
whole world change that's a big one and
also like you said inclusive stake
holding the incentive structures well
around that um two quick questions that
we like asking our guests on the way out
the first one is do you think we're in a
simulation okay
there's a gentleman named gates GA tes I
was blanking his first name is Sylvester
Gates I mean looked it up really quick
what's looking he's an African American
quantum physicist who's doing some
really cool stuff aster gates and he has
a big yeah right here yeah yeah this is
him Sylvester gate Googler case he had a
great bit on with Neil deGrasse Tyson
Bartok Yeah right and the other grass
ties into him got pretty deep into this
hole
theory I it's kind of multiple-choice
question / multiple-choice reality and
there's a lot of quantum physics that's
built into human perception so if you
perceive something you change it and
there's a lot of theories around what
you call Schrodinger's paradox or the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle again
my musing of both parents of both sides
were professors and my grandfather
taught a little bit of quantum physics
and quantum chemistry and other stuff so
I had we had these kind of dinner table
conversation but so I'm not a specialist
but family and other people around me
and I have a lot of friends who are
serious quantum physics people so my
take on it is that we live in a universe
that is an optimization of the realities
that are were possible so if you look at
Brian Greene who wrote a great book
called the elegant universe he's a
friend of mine he wrote the introduction
to two books of mine ago he has a theory
that there's multiple multiple universes
and the ones that we inhabit are
infinite but the fact that we perceive
them has drawn them out of probability
into manifesting our current situation
so the infinite possibility at every
thought which is kind of like mind
boggling and he's written whole series
of books he's at Columbia University
look him up Brian Greene great guy but
that also aligns with amusing enough
more ancient traditions of mathematics
and thinking mainly the and what
happened in India and the idea of
infinite universes as well yes India
mathematics in India really took a
different turn and Europe didn't have
the concept of zero until Fibonacci so
amusingly enough if all the numbers we
use like one two or three when you draw
them they're actually Sanskrit
they're called Arabic numerals but
actually the Arabs took them from the
Hindus so amusingly enough of all of our
mathematics and most of the things that
we're thinking about still goes back to
some very ancient thoughts about
infinite universes and potential and so
I actually am a big fan of saying that
it's all about research and reading yeah
I just want to show you a quick there's
one of my favorite photos in Stein with
rabid rats Agoura who is one of
his most famous poets and Einstein when
he was working on the general theory of
relativity until in line till you can
just google Einstein Indian poet Robert
Johnson gorg wow that's so cool I
appreciate you showing me that yeah that
bit was so good I'm the very last
question as we wrap here give me a go in
truth at next panel what is the most
beautiful thing in the world i io Wow
that's a deep one okay what is the most
beautiful thing in the world I think the
most beautiful thing in the world is
you're contemplating of the idea of
beauty getting people to really think
about all the potentials around you
so when you say thing and I'm more into
the idea of the thing so a lot of paul
this has been so fun at least we thank
you so much for coming on the show
really appreciate it thanks everyone for
tuning in we'd love to hear our thoughts
in the comments below check out the
links in the bio below to DJ DJ Spooky
go and follow him and go and check out
all of his incredible work and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world and continue
building incredible things with
organizations like the new s summit and
other great partners in your community
support them as well thank you very much
and we'll see you guys soon
peace
[Music]